SPEAKER_00: Good afternoon, Lisa. I know you wanted to discuss tax planning before year-end.
SPEAKER_01: Yes, I'm worried I'm going to owe a huge tax bill. My income jumped this year.
SPEAKER_00: Congratulations on the promotion. What's your new salary looking like?
SPEAKER_01: Base is one-forty now, plus I got a forty thousand signing bonus.
SPEAKER_00: Nice. So you're looking at about one-eighty total. That puts you in the... thirty-two percent bracket.
SPEAKER_01: Thirty-two percent? That seems like a lot.
SPEAKER_00: Well, that's just on income over one-seventy thousand. Your effective rate will be... uh, lower.
SPEAKER_01: Can you walk me through how that works?
SPEAKER_00: Sure. The first twenty-two thousand is taxed at ten percent, then twelve percent up to eighty-nine thousand...
SPEAKER_01: So it's like climbing a ladder?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Only the income in each bracket gets taxed at that rate. Very common misconception.
SPEAKER_01: That makes me feel a bit better.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Now, let's talk about what we can do to reduce your tax burden. Are you maxing out your 401k?
SPEAKER_01: I'm doing ten percent. Company matches up to six.
SPEAKER_00: So that's eighteen thousand in contributions. The limit this year is twenty-two five, so you could add more.
SPEAKER_01: How much would that save me?
SPEAKER_00: Every additional dollar saves you thirty-two cents in taxes. So forty-five hundred more would save about... let's see, fourteen forty.
SPEAKER_01: And the money still grows tax-deferred?
SPEAKER_00: Right. No taxes until you withdraw in retirement, presumably at a lower rate.
SPEAKER_01: What about a backdoor Roth conversion?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. At your income level, you can't contribute directly to a Roth IRA anymore.
SPEAKER_01: The income limits kicked in?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, phase-out starts at one-twenty-nine thousand for single filers. But you can do a backdoor conversion.
SPEAKER_01: How does that work exactly?
SPEAKER_00: You contribute sixty-five hundred to a traditional IRA with after-tax money, then immediately convert to Roth.
SPEAKER_01: And there's no tax on the conversion?
SPEAKER_00: Not if you convert right away. The contribution basis is the same as the conversion amount.
SPEAKER_01: Seems like a loophole.
SPEAKER_00: Congress has talked about closing it, but for now it's perfectly legal. Even the IRS acknowledges it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, that's another sixty-five hundred I can shelter.
SPEAKER_00: Well, it doesn't reduce your current taxes, but it grows tax-free forever.
SPEAKER_01: Right, I'm thinking long-term.
SPEAKER_00: Good mindset. Now, what about that signing bonus? Was it paid all at once?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, they hit me with the full forty thousand in March.
SPEAKER_00: Ouch. Bonuses get taxed at the supplemental rate - twenty-two percent federal, plus state and FICA.
SPEAKER_01: So I probably only netted about twenty-five thousand?
SPEAKER_00: Something like that. The good news is if you're overwithheld, you'll get a refund when you file.
SPEAKER_01: What do you mean overwithheld?
SPEAKER_00: Your actual tax rate might be lower than the twenty-two percent they withheld on the bonus.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, because of the marginal tax brackets?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Though with your higher income now, you might actually owe more than they withheld overall.
SPEAKER_01: How can I avoid a big surprise in April?
SPEAKER_00: Let's run a projection. What state are you in? California?
SPEAKER_01: Unfortunately, yes. I know the taxes are brutal.
SPEAKER_00: Top state rate is thirteen point three percent. Plus the one percent surcharge over a million, but... you're not there yet.
SPEAKER_01: Small mercies, I guess.
SPEAKER_00: So you're looking at about nine point three percent state tax on the income over eighty-four thousand.
SPEAKER_01: This is getting complicated.
SPEAKER_00: It is. That's why we should look at estimated tax payments to avoid underpayment penalties.
SPEAKER_01: I've never had to do those before.
SPEAKER_00: Your employer's withholding might not be enough with the income jump. The safe harbor is one-ten percent of last year's tax.
SPEAKER_01: What did I owe last year? About twelve thousand?
SPEAKER_00: So you'd need to pay thirteen thousand two hundred in total withholding and estimates to avoid penalties.
SPEAKER_01: And you think I'll owe more than that this year?
SPEAKER_00: Probably. Let me rough it out here... federal might be around twenty-eight thousand, state maybe twelve thousand.
SPEAKER_01: Forty thousand total? That's brutal.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, high earners really feel it. But remember, that's on one-eighty thousand of income.
SPEAKER_01: Still, it's like a luxury car payment.
SPEAKER_00: I know it stings. Let's focus on what we can control. Any business expenses you can deduct?
SPEAKER_01: I work from home sometimes. Can I claim a home office?
SPEAKER_00: Only if you're self-employed or it's your principal place of business. Employee home office deductions were eliminated.
SPEAKER_01: When did that happen?
SPEAKER_00: Tax Cuts and Jobs Act in twenty-eighteen. Lots of itemized deductions got suspended.
SPEAKER_01: What about unreimbursed business expenses?
SPEAKER_00: Same thing. Used to be deductible as a miscellaneous itemized deduction, but not anymore.
SPEAKER_01: This tax reform really hurt employees.
SPEAKER_00: In some ways, yeah. Though the standard deduction did double to twelve thousand nine-fifty.
SPEAKER_01: I've always itemized because of my mortgage.
SPEAKER_00: How much mortgage interest are you paying? And property taxes?
SPEAKER_01: About fifteen thousand in interest, eight thousand in property taxes.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, but remember property taxes are capped at ten thousand for the deduction.
SPEAKER_01: Right, the SALT limitation.
SPEAKER_00: So you're looking at twenty-five thousand in itemized deductions, which beats the standard deduction.
SPEAKER_01: Barely. What about charitable contributions?
SPEAKER_00: Those still count. How much do you typically give to charity each year?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe three thousand? I should probably give more.
SPEAKER_00: Well, with your higher income, you could consider bunching donations. Give two years' worth in one year.
SPEAKER_01: To exceed the standard deduction threshold?
SPEAKER_00: Right. Give six thousand this year, take the standard deduction next year when you give nothing.
SPEAKER_01: That seems kind of manipulative.
SPEAKER_00: It's just tax planning. You're giving the same amount over two years, just optimizing the timing.
SPEAKER_01: I guess that makes sense.
SPEAKER_00: You could also look into a donor-advised fund. Contribute appreciated stock instead of cash.
SPEAKER_01: How does that work?
SPEAKER_00: You donate stock you've held over a year, get a deduction for the full market value, and avoid capital gains tax.
SPEAKER_01: So it's like a double tax benefit?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Much more efficient than selling stock, paying taxes, then donating the after-tax proceeds.
SPEAKER_01: I've got some Apple stock that's done really well.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect candidate. What's your cost basis versus current value?
SPEAKER_01: I bought it at about fifty dollars, it's at one-ninety now.
SPEAKER_00: So you'd avoid capital gains tax on the one-forty dollar gain, plus get a charitable deduction.
SPEAKER_01: And I can recommend grants from the donor-advised fund over time?
SPEAKER_00: Right. Take the deduction this year when your income is high, then direct the money to charities later.
SPEAKER_01: That's pretty clever.
SPEAKER_00: It's a common strategy. Fidelity and Schwab both offer donor-advised fund platforms.
SPEAKER_01: Any other ways to reduce my tax bill?
SPEAKER_00: Well, if you're planning any major purchases, consider the timing. Maybe accelerate some expenses into this year.
SPEAKER_01: Like what kind of expenses?
SPEAKER_00: Medical expenses, if you have any planned procedures. They're deductible above seven point five percent of AGI.
SPEAKER_01: Seven point five percent of one-eighty... that's thirteen thousand five hundred.
SPEAKER_00: Right, so unless you have major medical expenses, probably not helpful.
SPEAKER_01: What about investment strategies?
SPEAKER_00: Tax-loss harvesting could help. Any positions in your taxable account that are underwater?
SPEAKER_01: I bought some tech stocks last year that haven't done well.
SPEAKER_00: You could sell those for losses to offset any gains you've realized this year.
SPEAKER_01: How much in losses can I deduct?
SPEAKER_00: Losses offset gains dollar for dollar. If you have net losses, you can deduct three thousand against ordinary income.
SPEAKER_01: And carry forward the rest?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Indefinitely, at three thousand per year against ordinary income.
SPEAKER_01: That's something at least.
SPEAKER_00: Just watch out for the wash sale rule. Can't buy the same security within thirty days.
SPEAKER_01: What if I want to maintain the position?
SPEAKER_00: Buy a similar but not identical security. Like VTI instead of VOO - both track the S&P 500.
SPEAKER_01: Close enough for tax purposes?
SPEAKER_00: The IRS hasn't given clear guidance on this, but most tax pros think substantially different funds are okay.
SPEAKER_01: Better to be safe though.
SPEAKER_00: Agreed. Now, looking ahead to next year, have you thought about maxing out an HSA?
SPEAKER_01: My company doesn't offer one. Just a regular health plan.
SPEAKER_00: Too bad. HSAs are triple tax-advantaged - deductible contribution, tax-free growth, tax-free withdrawals for medical.
SPEAKER_01: Best retirement account nobody talks about?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. You can even invest the money and use it for any purpose after sixty-five.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe I should look for a job with HSA options.
SPEAKER_00: Ha, don't change jobs just for the HSA. But it's a nice perk if you're ever job hunting.
SPEAKER_01: What about municipal bonds?
SPEAKER_00: Could make sense at your tax bracket. California munis yield about three point five percent tax-free.
SPEAKER_01: What's the taxable equivalent yield?
SPEAKER_00: At your combined federal and state rate, about... six point three percent.
SPEAKER_01: That's pretty competitive with CDs, right?
SPEAKER_00: It is, though munis have interest rate risk if you need to sell before maturity.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe a small allocation?
SPEAKER_00: Could work for money you don't need for several years. Just diversify across issuers.
SPEAKER_01: This has been really helpful.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Let me summarize the action items. Max out your 401k, do a backdoor Roth conversion...
SPEAKER_01: Tax-loss harvesting, maybe bunch some charitable contributions...
SPEAKER_00: Right, and consider making an estimated tax payment to avoid penalties.
SPEAKER_01: How much should I send in?
SPEAKER_00: Let me calculate this... probably around five thousand to be safe.
SPEAKER_01: Due by January fifteenth?
SPEAKER_00: For Q4, yes. Though if you do all these other strategies, you might not need that much.
SPEAKER_01: Better safe than sorry.
SPEAKER_00: Agreed. Underpayment penalties aren't huge, but why give the IRS free money?
SPEAKER_01: Exactly. Thanks for all the advice.
SPEAKER_00: You're welcome. High-income earners have more planning opportunities, but also more complexity.
SPEAKER_01: I'm definitely learning that.
SPEAKER_00: We'll revisit everything in January once you have your year-end pay stubs and tax documents.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds good. I'll get started on these strategies.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. Don't wait too long - December goes by fast.